come cazzo sono arrivato qui quando
guardo guardano gol è da tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono
fatti j ed egiziano su aver globo
andiamo cosa ho detto siamo al sud dove
tanto lo sapete che non so quando la
porca [ __ ] perché dovevo fare una
serie subito game del quale non riesco
neanche a dire il nome porca [ __ ] va
bene questo avrebbe la tecnico ragazzi
velate dico ok perfetto non so neanch'io
che cosa ho fatto mai stato figo proprio
come cadere a terra come in un
deficiente lunga ragazzi una cosa che
volevo dire a parte questo è che mi
avete detto se non attimo che devo fare
una cosa troppo [ __ ]
minchia volo peggio di superman range
arona il culo minchiam e l'apparato come
cazzo ha fatto uso solo lui guarda
dietro a grazie mi salvi gli serviva un
bel massaggio ma chi è tenero si succhia
il pollice ragazzi queste queste sono
cose che vanno ricordate mi chiamo
alcuni scatti una foto che avete detto
che premendo non mi ricordo 64 anzi
infatti quattro tipo se bloccato
io io cambio posso cambiare aspetto è
così trasformazione in aria che cos'è
qualche appunto allora son diventato un
lupo della madonna che mi lui pensa di
poter battere un lupo che due volte lui
ma [ __ ] ancora cazzola casa no perché
ci abbiamo si stimi di stuzzicadenti in
mano ferma cosa vuoi fare con quel coso
te lo infilo nel culo se continui così
bravo che ti avevo detto zio allora
fermo fermo
non ho niente contro i tagli ucciso
lewitt e ucciso l'altro defilandosi un
caffè ma dopo purga budan a ciò è
successo davvero asi chissenefrega
ragazzi l'importante e tirare calci in
faccia alla gente che meno sono state
l'ipo questo è morto senza l ho fatto
male col cazzo mi sa che sei un po
insaccato qualcuno c'è mi dà una mano
perché esso tizio la devo portare in
infermeria
se senti mi dai una mano tu che sto
tizio si sente male svenuto prima
guardava troppa televisione eva guai che
sinistro reagente guarda come sto
sanguinando
ma ce l'hai un cuore e stronzo prendi la
dany boon a chi è basato su cavo
guardali ma [ __ ] comunque che
cazzate molto prima per trasformarmi 44
cioè io sono sono diventato un lupo ma
gli altri che cazzo
un odio che figo è addio sono diventato
un robot conigli 86 milano sto tizio
cioè un dildo tanto non mi fa in un la
tua
come non detto che cosa cazzo è sta roba
allora questo deve essere un gatto
alquanto letale mista secondo me non
bisogna farsi ingannare dall'apparenza
era come non detto sono casca sono morto
sei utile come un dito nel deretano la
mattina guardali separate guardare
mamma mia mamma mia mamma mi guardano
[Musica]
aiuto ragazzi aiuto lupo scelgo te
il cazzo è peggio di pikachu vai con
mamma mia che potenza sto tizio non puoi
il calore in arrivo nicchia come cazzo
fatto o la e lei stupito ninja e lupi
tonin già ma torna l l'ufficio più
letale del mondo perché furbo come una
volpe è scaltro kemon coniglio ragazzi
sta cosa sta cosa
guardali montali guardali come succube e
sulla paura c'è paura la bertolaso paura
lo sento brutto stronzo
ragazzi io mi teme mi anche mia nonna
la cosa bellissima e che non è mi possa
trasformare i colori perché ho lasciato
la spada prendi la cioè le mani troppo
grosse per me che sono stuzzicadenti
ragazzi va bè non importa senti mi serve
devo potermi i denti zio grazie ragazzi
è troppo forte sto tizio non ce n'è cioè
vincere troppo facile vincere questo
tizio guardarli guardali come cazzo
fatto che sente di mezzo le lance
ragazzi ma come cazzo è possibile che
ogni volta ci danno un coltello sempre
più lungo è questo dovette al infila zio
allora sa cosa ho letto come non è
durato un secondo ragazzi allora fermi
che devo prendere come si fa come si
cosa premo si ok non riuscire a farmi un
attimo che sta roba fa male se messa nel
dell'età me ve lo dico voi non provateci
a casa brutto strà allora come io ho
usato disarm armi lurido pezzente di
merda guardali roma suo cause che posso
farla c'è il globo tir con il cos'è
questo c'è ma voi avete mai visto un
cane più figo di questo non va bene
io io non ho parole raga ma lui sa già
di vincere perché lui mangia crocchette
energetica la mattina forse non così
tante ragazzi voglio sentire un bel coro
forza favi che perché non vi sento più
forte amico mio non ha esultato nessuno
per noi ma tutti i nuovi in modo
tremendamente sexy fatelo dire matrix ti
ho bisogno di te
mamma mi hai fatto ma guarda che è
stronzo sia nuvole o fornisce le sfide
le battaglie vogliamo battaglia vj ok
non fa niente tu le mani giù le mani
trucco niglio mi cassetti piglio amico
mio devi capire che se io ballo devi
ballare anche tu non qualche pezzo di me
in guardia vai così ho fatto alcuna
napoleone anche prima ragazzi sa cosa
non l'ho capita ma non importa perché
vado al rallenty perché sono phil goss e
poi ho paura fare giravolte coast omega
stuzzicadenti non si sa mai
ecco come non detto amico via mi sa che
tu non hai capito proprio con chiaia che
farete la vostra subito hai qualcosa da
dire per caso ma perché non ti sto
sentendo com'è che adesso scappano ma
vieni qua giocavo lì che scappo allora
vedi che le dimensioni contano brutto
stronzo asi sfidare ma è brutto stronzo
ragazzi 6 una mano mi ha capito lo
chiama che fare no perché sono stupide
ma veramente parecchio gioca ragazzi era
tutta una tattica faccio finta di
letture e poi lo piglio per mamma mia
che potenza ragazzi sun
mi sto sanguinando un orecchio ok forse
non era musica buona orecchio mi son
rotto l'orecchio oggi sono rotto non è
che c'è un cerotto a buffalo porge
straja ragazzi coniglio di ge volte che
ci cambia che evoluzione di merda in
faccia
minchia che botta si allunga madonna
neanche buffon si è allungato mai così
ho vinto ho vinto è l'uomo lupo che
l'attacco ai conigli se li fai male in
culo a te lo guardano guardo al ceppo
teche possenza store scoperso naggio
sono finite le crocchette
ma stai scherzando lurido stronzo dove
ti permette questo studiando lo sta
studiando saltando da un muro all'altro
e si prepara alla botta madonna mi
rialzerò e vincerò questa guerra perché
io sono sono caduto a ma mi rialzerò
ancora perché io sono sono il re del
coni
ma [ __ ] maicon dio come chiasso
sono arrivato qui quando guardo guardano
gol di già chiare tema donna ibrahimovic
non saprebbe fare di meglio che direi
che posso anche dare un pò in faccia
cosa cosa fa limiti per me come baffo
ancora qualcosa mi dice che gli ho fatto
malissimo comunque lurido ma [ __ ]
devo vincere la provincia perché
l'ultima devo vincere ma abbiamo vinto
guardali madonna ma non ha nessuna tutte
ragazzi è stato incredibile comunque
direi che posso concludere qui perché ho
dato dimostrazione all'arena che ci so
fare e sono sono esausto di giorni che
sono più stanco io che sto cazzo di con
i due ragazzi vi ringrazio comunque di
nuovo per il traguardo dei 500 mila
iscritti per gli amanti farò lo speciale
ovviamente e quindi come al solito
ragazzi se video è piaciuto lasciato
argomento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che come non invidio trovate
nella descrizione se ne sente con
iscritti scrivete venirci vediamo perché
cazzo mi combattete davanti 200 siti
scriveteli ci rivediamo il prossimo vito
bella ragazzi